[Musique]
cette semaine dans l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois nous avons
le temps attendue libérée délivré et oui
vous l'aurez reconnu la reine des neiges
2 est programmé pour au moins deux
semaines à l'espace philippe noiret
l'intrigué du film tourne autour de ce
questionnement pourquoi elsa est elle
née avec des pouvoirs magiques
son rêve est de le découvrir avec l'aide
de ses amis anna christophe l'a fait
sienne
nous vous donnons également rendez vous
pour notre événement cinéma jeudi 28
novembre à 14 heures ce sera signée thé
ou café en vous faisant redécouvrir le
film lulu femme nue et de solveig
anspach avec karin viard
vous la retrouverez également dans le
film chanson douche programmé à l'espace
philippe noiret la semaine prochaine
cette semaine nous avons également le
film à couteaux tirés de ryan johnson un
drame policier riche en couleurs
surmonté de touche d'humour vous
transportera dans un univers semblable
au célèbre jeu de société super credo
harlan trombert en place le docteur
lenoir ce célèbre auteur de polar est
retrouvé mort dans sa somptueuse
propriété
le soir de ses 85 ans c'est le détective
benoît blanc interprété par le
charismatique daniel craig qui est alors
engagée par un commanditaire anonyme
afin d'élucider la faire mais entre la
famille d'alan qui s'entre déchirent et
son personnel qui lui reste dévoué blanc
plonge dans les méandres d'une enquête
mouvementée mais leurs mensonges et
fausses pistes où les rebondissements
s'enchaînent à un rythme effréné
jusqu'à la toute dernière minute une
oeuvre qui sera vous plaire c'est
pourquoi nous vous invitons à venir la
voir à l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]